Okay Michael so before we get started diving into
a particular formalism or framework that I want to
talk about, that we are going to use for
this mini course or at least the first half or
so of it. I want to remind everybody what
the differences are between the three types of learning
that we said we are going to look at
over this entire course. Th, you recall what they are?
>> Well reading off the slides supervised, unsupervised and reinforcement.
>> That's right. And you know, again these things are all strongly
related to one other but it's very useful to think about them as being very
separate. So just as a reminder, supervised learning
sort of takes the form of function approximation
where you're given a bunch of x, y pairs And your goal is to find
a function f that will map some new x to a proper y, you recall that?
>> Yep.
>> Unsupervised learning is very similar to supervised learning except that
it turns out that you're given a bunch of x's
and your goal is to find some f. That gives
you a compact description of the set of x's that
you've seen. So we call this clustering, or description as
opposed to function approximation, and finally we're getting to reinforcement
learning. Now reinforcement learning is actually a, a name that
means many things in different fields, and here we tend
to talk about it in a relatively specific way, and
superficially it looks a lot like Supervised learning, in
that we're going to be given a string of pairs
of data, and we're going to try to learn some
functions. But in the function approximation case, a supervized learning
case, we were given a bunch of X and Y pairs. We were asked to learn F, but
in reinforcement learning, we were given something totally different.
Were instead going to be given x's and z's, and
I'll tell you what the x's and the z's stand for in
a minute, and then were going to have to learn some f that
is going to generate y's, and so even though its going to look
a lot like function approximation, its going to turn out that it's going to
have a very different character. And that's really what the, the next
few slides in a little bit of discussion is really about, is
understanding what that character is. You'll also notice from the title here
that I have decision making reinforcement
learning, and that's because reinforcement learning is
one mechanism for doing decision making. And again, I'll define
that in just a second. Okay, so you with me, Michael?
>> I think so. So should y be circled?
because in some sense, you, you underlined the things we
were given and you circled the things we needed to
find, so y is something that we're going to find, right?
>> Yeah, I suppose that I like that.
>> All right. Interesting.
>> Now it's a theta.
>> [LAUGH] It's a Y trapped inside of a theta and it's yelling, Y?
>> [LAUGH] I like that. I'm a Y
trapped in a theta. Hm, I need to write a book
about that. Okay, good. That's a good point Michael. So before
we were learning, effectively trying to learn one thing and here
we're still learning one thing. Because it's going to produce another thing
for the deterministically, usually. But it's worth pointing out that we
are going to be figuring how to produce both of these things
as opposed to be given those things. Good job. OK. Are
you ready to move forward,l Michael, with an example and a quiz?
>> Awesome.
>> Excellent.